[Music]
you saw a cliff of the weekend just
flailing his tongue around what can we
search that on YouTube Just weekend
concert tongue
[Applause]
this looks like a filter I know that's
why I thought it was a bit at first I
was watching it I was thinking like oh
this is like some hilarious filter and
it's like gonna cut to multiple angles
of him just that's really him doing that
that's him yep
no I was gonna say this actually feels
like a horror film yeah seriously like
just the red and the screaming like no
please yeah no he's coming closer
imagine [__] like I'm trying to think
of the Imagine [__] imagine like
Adele goes on stage and mid performance
just starts going
you know what I mean
oh oh
I mean women artists have done the same
like similar things whoo
uh like that no like it's not up front
uh who am I thinking of it's like a
like a modern artist mid hello
I mean that would go crazy search lady
deep throats microphone this
[Music]
oh it's about to go
she spit on it oh
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you know there's a boyfriend in the
audience of this show like
[Music]
[Applause]
he's touching the balls
she's caressing
no search on YouTube art installation
microphone
suck Riley Reed impulsive no no no no no
no
no like actually surgeon you trying to
watch It Again Luke
yeah dude why'd you bookmark that
I mean we know why
it's this lady
it's like a shotgun microphone
it must have been deleted it's it's the
most odd it's just how do you know all
these clips
because I'm chronically online I guess
I'm a nerd it's crazy that I was like
man what if the girl did like what if
this obscure happened you're like here's
the video right I I can't tell you how
many conversation or conversations I've
ruined recently I mean that's just this
whole podcast isn't it like it's just
you being like can you imagine I'm like
yeah no that exists here it is no but
she's just sitting in the middle of a
circle in an empty space at an exhibit
and it's a shotgun microphone skinny as
hell and she's just just slide whistling
that thing oh why this is like a museum
goer it's just an art installation of
people wear though uh yeah it looks like
it said a museum and the people are just
sitting there like there's no like rope
around it or anything no so people are
trying to figure out is it recording
yeah those make a world later yeah but
people are like so like the idea of the
art installation is like oh is it
recording do we speak into it what
happens and this girl was like um what
if I throwed it no no she it's her
performance
so she's part of it yeah she's just oh
maybe it starts that put performance art
microphone head deep throat can you
Google it
I'm not crazy this video exists
you should be more explicit microphone
head or something or deep throat
I think that person is going to Garner
oh second one
what did I tell you you're right ah
why did I think I thought there were
people there she's just like in a this
is just like a she's in her basement
she's like yeah check this out watch
this on PornHub or something you're not
ready you're not ready I love this is
how
this is how uh like internet headlines
used to be yeah no one had figured out
click bait yeah so just being really on
the nose you are not prepared for this
video yeah
this is not just a still image this is a
video this is an actual piece of content
get out we got something
we got one of them 12.
oh yeah there are people it sounds like
there's people there
maybe not
[Music]
I didn't remember another dude
I didn't
this is totally different from the
from the frame of the other one though
yeah
yeah she's done multiple yo honestly
this is a Dope music video yeah so just
put Modest Mouse behind this
yo should I sample this yeah should I
make a b out of this yeah
[Music]
this hurts
yeah make it stop
ah damn
he's giving that thing love dude
[Music]
see there you go that's the sound Cody
was looking for
oh yeah so imagine if Adele
yeah so now so imagine now hello it's me
oh
hello I'll tell you what it'd be hella
saw Dell in Vegas right how was the show
hella horny 40 year old men in that area
exactly
yeah
honey I think we should go to the Adele
concert
again
I would like to go to the Adele concert
honey
can you believe this Adele she's out
there blowing the microphone
you like it though
just a delicate kiss on the for me
a delicate kiss on your scrotum
[Music]
that's a good one yeah dude you deserve
points for that
yeah
well
I think it's that time
to wrap it up
it's not for an art installation how's
this for an art installation
[Laughter]
here's an art installation it's just us
swinging a microphone around broken
glass
hey how's this
foreign
that's cute
he's wearing a sombrero nice dude
nice oh no look at mine it's an
alcoholic
oh no stop I think give me your keys
um
is this the both of these nuts candle
it smells like bananas
old bananas
all right guys I think we have to go
oh
Trump supporter
nice
[Music]
thanks
for sure
my microphone is Fred Durst
this is a weird way to end it